I shot in uh eight times everybody moved
a merchant guarding his property you got
anybody out there or just for sure
Romero out here all of the merchants
here are not going to wait for the
National Guard or police or anybody else
you talked about guerrilla warfare and
it's right here right on the premises
here just about every one of the
individuals in this radio Korea quickly
became dubbed koreatown's makeshift
Command Center warning listeners of the
whereabouts of incoming looters and
offered itself as a 9-1-1 system
allowing shop owners to call out for
help over the air after the realization
sank in there would be no response from
police fire or EMS already stretched too
thin responding to thousands of ongoing
emergencies
[Music]
we need a traditional Garden here we
have no police support whatsoever people
are driving by shooting at us and we
have to do something about it a local
resident by the name of Aina Cho and
president of the Korean veterans
association in 1992 was listening to the
broadcast and decided to call in a
little broadcast of his own requesting
all Korean Marine Corps veterans to
respond to the area soon after a group
of around 15 Korean Marine Corps
veterans arrived equipped with rifles
and rendezvous with Cho the men
responded to a large Electronics
Warehouse Kim's TV where radio Korea was
broadcasting that a mob of looters were
attempting to break in the warehouse had
an iron door which the mob was beating
and ramming with a truck when the mob
finally took down the door Cho attempted
to stop the looters who were sprinting
inside when two vehicles with a combined
occupation of 10 people got out of their
cars and opened fire on show hitting him
one time Richard Kim whose parents owned
the electronics store armed himself with
a semi-automatic rifle as the warehouse
house was Under Fire his mother suffered
a gunshot wound while trying to Shield
his father and as more Koreans became
injured more and more Koreans took up
arms taking positions on rooftops for
maximum tactical Advantage not only did
they have The High Ground and could see
everything from the roof but parapets
made for the perfect cover from incoming
fire and these fire fights were
televised we're more familiar with
Weaponry than I am he says it looks to
be a nine millimeter Uzi where Korean
shopkeepers could be seen armed with M1
carbines Ruger mini-14s pump action
shotguns handguns and Daewoo k1a ones
like look at this dude's Loadout he's
got a red Polo t-shirt and a Daewoo k1a1
I mean come on one of the most iconic
photographs of roof Koreans happened at
a small grocery store called California
Market the owner fortified his store
with 20 well-armed employees and
volunteers all of whom were wearing
white headbands they were often shooting
blanks or discharging warning shots into
the air which is dumb gotta gotta wonder
where those went you know but their
methods worked as looters third fleeing
the area as quickly as they could
on May 3rd after four days of exchanging
gunfire with armed looters the rooftop
Koreans successfully forced every single
wave of remaining mobs out of Koreatown
saving countless lives and livelihoods
in which the korean-american identity
was born
and on that same day over 1100 Marines
and 6 500 National Guard troops
patrolled the streets of Los Angeles
putting an end to the chaos
if it wasn't for a few brave men who
stood up against their opposers
Koreatown would have been unsalvageable
the nearly week-long rioting killed more
than 60 people injuring more than in
salvageable the new Brave man who stood
up against their opposers Koreatown
would have been unsalvageable the nearly
week-long rioting killed more than 60
people injuring more than 2 300 and
caused approximately one billion dollars
in damage half of which was sustained by
Korean owned businesses Korean Americans
have come to refer to the 1992 Uprising
is saigu which translates to April 29th
a day Koreans will never forget
four two nine hey guys if you enjoyed
this video
it's a moment of profound sadness and
loss of feeling so targeted and so
abandoned
minorities attacking each other because
of economic poverty
um these poor black people and poor
white people attacking Koreans because
the country that they live in hasn't
taken care of them obviously I
sympathize with people who are [ __ ]
being attacked
by people in their stores are getting
looted but
why is that happening probably because
we're taking care of people very well
um
it would be nice if the police did their
job and the Koreans wouldn't have had to
defend themselves
uh but you know this is a jungle this is
like a [ __ ]
free No Holds Barred just free for all
here
so
um if that's the case then it's badass
to take up arms and fight people off but
that's obviously that's not a very
sustainable solution you can't just
expect people to do that all the time
um ideally you'd have police forces that
actually do their job instead of just
sitting in Beverly Hills
where no one was looting anything just
to keep the rich white people safe
and that the police would actually be
there to help protect people and keep
people safe and keep the community
intact but that's not what the job of
police are and when there's a moment of
Crisis you see what their instincts are
like well who really gives a [ __ ] the
poor people are attacking each other
we don't really care about poor people
um their job is to
um
preserve the status quo and the wealth
distribution as it currently exists
through physical Force
so if poor people are really attacking
each other they don't care
um
this is what you'd rather have us
against each other sounds low roof
Korean rooftop Koreans you and Tony are
the forces of stopping Asian hate haha
um yeah this is
a fun little thing that we're doing
right now it's a little broadcast
um
we could play something crazy
um
let's just look at news
what is the news today YouTube
Trump got raided
uh which is fun
let's just look at b-roll footage on
mute of trump getting raided
luckily my internet is really slow
um but yeah obviously some people who
are really political are really into
talking about this like it's a big deal
I don't think it's really that big a
deal
uh I mean we all know who Trump purports
to be and who
he acts who he tries to portray himself
as is it really surprising that he broke
the law and that the police are in are
the police are investigating him
like he was just doing whatever the [ __ ]
he wanted what why why wouldn't he get
investigated
um
I think it makes sense that he probably
[ __ ] something up he probably did
something wrong
of all the presidents to get raided it
makes sense that it would be him
um yeah I mean I don't really feel bad
for him he did so much damage to the
country and he botched the coronavirus
response which killed
uh more people than it should have
uh yeah [ __ ] him
he's a politician
um
yeah I I don't understand anyone who's
like oh poor Trump we gotta protect him
[ __ ] him he's he put himself out there
he's going for gold you risk it all this
is the game he decided to pay
heard you have a good joke about women's
sports let's hear it
I can't wait to see an Irvine I'm going
to California soon the tour dates are on
my details and my about section on the
video it links to my link tree and the
link tree is a link of all the places
that I'm going to be in California I'm
going to go to Oxnard Irvine
San Jose other places
what was up with the headbands it's just
like uh the headbands and the roof
Korean video was a way to
um distinguish
that they were doing something they're
like we're doing something now
we're all here doing this thing
so it's just a way to like
tell people that they're doing something
or to concentrate and
you know it just displays through
fashion what uh that they're up to
something
like oh they're wearing a uniform and
it's like a physical reminder that that
they're there for a purpose in Korea and
a lot of protests people were headbands
that say stuff on it
um
it's like a way to display things and
write words on it and communicate
there's a large protest culture in Korea
because
the U.S installed a puppet dictator a
military dictatorship in oh look Chinese
people doing it in Korea and South Korea
that was murdering students and killing
people that they suspected was Chinese
and basically just kept the uh
government that was in place for the
Japanese Occupation intact
so it's like there were evil people the
worst Koreans like the Uncle Tom of
Koreans Who Sold Koreans out to Japanese
people just were the head of the
government in South Korea and uh and
then we found a new daddy America and
then a lot of those people stayed
and uh were going around killing their
enemies slash communists
um
look and even in America
they got little words on their little
headband
so there was a lot of protests a lot of
people wanted democracy and they finally
achieved it in the 80s or 90s or
something
but yeah Korea was uh doing worse than
North Korea
where they were they had
like a lot of massacres
where they would Massacre a lot of
Korean people that were suspected of
being communists
and they had a very right-wing
government that was crushing the left
wing and the unions and the people that
are fighting for workers rights so there
were a lot of protests there were a lot
of students getting killed a lot of
police uh
you know uh horrible acts by the place
in South Korea
so they have a lot of uh
on a protest a lot of protests in Korea
kill [ __ ] oh no South Korean protests
against Japan over islets
that's the thing they have these islands
called tokto Island
that uh you know that's just how Koreans
communicate us with headbands
but yeah they're fighting against
the Japanese there's like some islands
that no one really cares about that
don't really do anything that they're
like fighting for for no reason
um and it's just like a [ __ ] ego
battle it's like this is my Island I
will get this island and it just like
becomes a whole thing it's just like
turf wars
uh
should we do headband protests also I
mean it'd be nice it's just like a way
because people are always looking at
your face anyways you might as well
write something on there that displays
what you're feeling if you're at a
protest so that people can just look at
your face and see what what's going on
ideologically in your head
um but yeah
should we buy Pokemon to help the cause
sure should we do a headband or test
um you and Tony and young what was up
with the headbands you might just seeing
Irma
already read all these
Oxnard are you serious I'll come see you
yeah check out the descriptions in the
YouTube video I'm going to California
the most populous state in the Union a
big old State full of people which is
great because I do stand-up comedy for
people
and California has a lot of people so it
works out
Japanese people scare this guy
um Japanese people are you know they
were pretty horrible during World War II
I think the um their culture they come
from the islands of Japan this lady is
like all over the news
uh the islands of Japan were very War
warring they had a lot of Wars they had
so many factions and
shogunates
they were always fighting they got good
at fighting they're on a small island
they can't escape each other they have
to fight it out and they uh they got
good at fighting and they're like well
we're good at this let's [ __ ] use
this
um
but yeah
I think it's just
how
they're kind of competitive and this can
be good it can be bad
but uh yeah they really did a good job
at some things in World War II and a lot
of bad things as well
uh and they kind of are kind of trying
to sweep it under the rug for the most
part
uh in terms of their education and stuff
but
I feel like Japanese people are in
general are Asian and nice they're too
Asian to be mean they're too respectful
of individuals
just if you get them in a group and
point them at a minority
and it's not good like Filipinos
um
yes there's a lot going on get that
movement down with the blink stock
[Music]
um
so what do you guys think about the
whole crisis of trump getting arrested
and raided is that a big deal or is it
not
let's hear from the listeners
um I think that uh Trump getting raided
is not a big deal
uh I think that he deserves it he
definitely did something wrong
um let's see
you guys want to
call in
um my favorite Asians Koreans but I'm
biased if I wasn't Korean I would say
the best Asians are probably
uh Chinese definitely then Japanese and
Korean because China is just such a
[ __ ] force of nature they just
[ __ ]
they just get their [ __ ] together and
they dominate they dictate culture the
language the architecture
it's all Chinese
um I don't know how they did it but they
did it so you got to respect that
um and Japanese people are good at
making Sony's and Nintendos and stuff so
um
let me know if you want to call in
call into my
call into my uh Instagram
um my favorite
Vietnamese people are great
I feel like uh Southern Asian people are
more closely
linked to African Americans and upper
Northern Asian people are more
culturally similar to whites
Vietnamese people are very uh
you know into feeling good and having a
good time and then Northern Asians are
into
uh discipline and boredom and
uh
studying and just
being white
having a stick up your ass and not
enjoying anything
um
yeah so Trump got raided
and then he had to Pro he had to put in
a thing at the
whatever at the New York deposition he
pleaded the fifth
there is some guy that's going around
killing Muslims and he looks Mexican is
there a Mexican killing Muslims
why would that be
Muhammad Syed
wait so he's a Muslim guy killing other
Muslims
why would a Muslim kill other Muslims
that's scary when someone's just like
got a mission
a mission to go attack people he looks
like he's trying to smile what a creepy
dude
I can't believe a Muslim was killing
other Muslim
why is he killing other Muslims is he
like I can be the only one I don't want
other people to be
Muslim I want to be like the token
Muslim guy I want to have more
I don't know
well at least he was Muslim that's at
least it was Muslim on Muslim violence
it's scarier if it's from outside the
thing
um
is there a news site I trust I just try
to look at it all
like I don't trust Fox News but other
than that
I um I think most news sites are pretty
accurate just like
the bias you have to look out for and
like how they try to frame things
but this the facts like oh Muslim guy
killed Muslims maybe the fact that we're
paying attention to it is we're in
mandated from blunt force charmouse and
North Austin store
oh wow
that's in Austin Austin report airport
oh this is local news
let me screen after terminal evacuation
private property creeps into Austin's
public roadways
what does that mean
I don't want public property to be
encroached upon
oh so slow
anyways R.I.P the victims
yes
a tough one of the difference actually
is on than other religions at times
um I mean I don't know if he was
targeting them because they were SUNY
and he was Shiite
or maybe he was just targeting them in
general
unless and knights have increasingly
claimed ownership of the public parking
spots in front of their properties
my neighbor is doing this my neighbor
gets pissed off at me when I park in
front of his house this year marks the
25th anniversary of Austin's residential
pyramid parking program
I got part of the nearly 70 percent of
the specifically especially designated
blocks were approved in the decade
leading up to the pandemic
I have a car permanent Financial attacks
on the sales department starts at twenty
dollars
to limit parking in front of their homes
that's the thing about having a car
based infrastructure you start being
really possessive of your parking spots
but that's a large amount of surface
area that you need that could be going
for something more useful if you didn't
have to have an exoskeleton called a car
to get anywhere imagine if you had to
[ __ ] hop into a robot suit anytime
you wanted to go get a pack of smokes or
you know a Slim Jim it's like this is
not an efficient way to do things it
takes way too much money and resources
and destroys environment way too much
for you to just go out your door
that's the thing is like
I live in the suburbs and
people are like oh freedom but like 99
of the suburb that I live in I can't go
to because it's someone else's property
and like 99 of the surface area in the
suburbs is a place where you could get
shot
so I am constantly walking around other
people's property who are itching to
defend it because that's the only way
they interact with Society is by
attacking each other
because they're all in their little
castle just hold off from each other
there's no Community there's no place
where we meet there's no place where
people can do things here it's just all
houses there's not a store there's not
like a little lounging area it's just
all houses houses where
people have decided that they will kill
you if you show up there so it doesn't
make me feel that good to be here where
people are so close to their Killing
Zone where they feel justified in
killing anyone
um
so it's just
it's just not a great uh
not a great uh environment
where people are just like so
um
so close to killing you if you just
stray a little bit
so this is
um something that is interesting
so they these people can block off the
area in front of their homes even though
all austinites pay city taxes to
maintain public roadways
so it's just interesting
to uh cordon off public roads
and say that you need to only certain
people can park here
which is fine you know I don't really
want to park in front of most people's
homes anyways you have your shitty real
estate to yourself
I don't want to park over in you know
some stupid neighborhood
buds Creek
but it just makes it harder and more
difficult for people to get along and
hang out
it'd be better if uh
we all could get along
streams struggle to find drivers
police investigating homicide
some person died woman cry arrested on
dwrf Crash trans man into Hospital
um but yeah I mean car based
infrastructure is very dangerous and
toxic
um I think that uh it's dangerous to
have everyone going 60 miles per hour
it's better to build everything close so
you don't have to get in a car to go
everywhere
um
I think ideally you would be able to go
down and walk around because you have to
get out of your car eventually
but I grew up our neighborhood used to
just fight each other in the front yards
of their double wide trailers over it
right here man it's true on people being
so possessive no committee it's like
these guys just because I just were
killing Ahmad Arbury and you haven't
gotten out too I bet Rogan doesn't worry
about this stuff
I'm a bit dumb not to keep strangers off
your property or protect it yeah I know
it's great to have your own little place
but a whole neighborhood shouldn't just
be houses
it should have a store and a laundromat
and [ __ ] that people want to go to
instead of just like house house house
this is where we live this is where we
have fun this is where we have sex it's
like every little area is so different
it's like why don't we just combine it
together
and uh you know create communities that
you can do everything in
instead of just rows and rows of houses
it's just so sterile and it doesn't
create a community that area is dead
this area is like nobody is hanging out
or having fun or doing anything
I mean it's the American thing they
wanted to make it expensive to buy a
house so that black people wouldn't live
near them
they wanted to create the Haves and the
haves not they wanted to create
Plantation
uh things because that's what our
country was built upon
you know exploiting
slaves and whatever so you got to have a
place for the rich and the place for the
poor
and now the only way you can hang out
you can't just hang out with just the
general population of America you have
to hang out with people that you have
met and you only have close
relationships
and there's no like sort of medium
relationships
we talk about how great a job Austin's
homeless father was at this before Big
Brother stepped in
yeah I heard that they put them all up
in hotels and just got them off the
street
but you know until you address the root
of the problem which is wealth
inequality and employers not playing
paying employees enough is going to
happen as long as you're like we need to
help employers keep as much of their
money as possible you're gonna have
homeless people because employers are
taking too much of the money what's your
favorite Korean food probably
play City skylines I wish I could play
City skylines
so they should move to a city I thought
that's what Austin was
but yeah I like Austin I don't like the
infrastructure here or the way that it's
built but I do like Austin
um I mean in America you can't really
get away from suburban sprawl and all
that [ __ ]
uh uh so in terms of a city that is
Suburban sprawled it's not bad
uh it's one of the best Suburban
sprawled cities
out there
um
so yeah I like the city I like being
here even though it's suburban sprawl
and they built highways everywhere and
it takes forever to get anywhere
I I still like it here you know
it's one of the best cities that is like
that
um have you been kayaking yeah I've been
kayaking it's pretty great what's your
favorite conspiracy theory
Austin is little Kelly to the rest of
Texas yes it is it's the most liberal
place but uh it's still not uh
California it's still very Texas like
the roads here are very sprawled and
stuff
but yeah
it's a good place I like it
you can always tell who's from Austin if
you're from anywhere else in Texas
yeah Texas is a really cool place I'm
just getting used to it
um you know Houston versus Dallas is a
big one Houston and Dallas are the
biggest cities that the most cultural
sway than San Antonio and then Austin
and then like the [ __ ]
uh Gulf Coast people and then you got El
Paso and then all the little towns in
between
but uh yeah I like it it's a beautiful
beautiful place
um I'm not really paying attention but
hopefully that's a good spot
I need sheep and brick
brick is gonna be hard to come by
uh Rock would be nice too
but uh yeah
it's we legal in Texas no way they're
too stubborn they don't want to admit
they were wrong they don't want to be
like yeah sorry we uh accidentally
made weed illegal for no reason they're
like [ __ ] you we're gonna keep it
illegal
because
we don't care about anything
I hope you enjoyed listening to me drink
it was a bit more of a gulp than I
wanted it to be
um I'm thinking of going here and then
leading up to there
just because I have the wood port
why not
hopefully no one goes
anywhere over here which though probably
will
this guy needs sheep and Rock
so he might go there and then this guy
needs sheep and
brick
so he might go here
oh interesting
this guy needs sheep and Rock
so I'm guessing he's going here
maybe here
maybe here
just don't go here because I want to go
right here
but uh yeah I mean
ah nice
interesting
I don't know what I'm gonna do
probably gonna go for here first
just so I don't get cut off
but uh where should I stay away from if
moving to Austin
uh the only thing about Austin is that
you could live pretty far away I would
say don't live in the suburbs
um
just try to get close
even though rent in Austin is so
expensive
I'll move here so you guys can see the
game
um
God no wood
has been wrong
um but yeah I would say the
neighborhoods in Austin are as follows
there is the North Austin domain area
which is like bougie and rich in upper
class and [ __ ] and there's the South
Austin which is poor and students are
and artists and stuff then there's
uh
West Austin which is the hills where all
the rich people live and then East
Austin is where all the poor poor
minorities live
um but yeah I would say if you're
looking for a place Riverside is good
because it's so cheap there
uh Riverside is like south of the river
a little bit South it's East or it's uh
it's East by South
it's East by Southeast so it's more East
than it is
uh anything else
I'm gonna go here
hopefully this guy doesn't have two
roads because he could cut me off
now I just need a brick
[Music]
um
he better not have two oh thank God
foreign
[Applause]
place I love the energy I love the
attitude
you know there is a lot of issues that I
have with uh
Society but you know
it's not as bad as it could be
um even through it all I think Americans
are very unique and special and we
really shine
in many ways
which is nice
the computer seems a little slower for
whatever reason
I think I'm gonna have to build right
here just in case because it's really
important
that I have that
even though I could have built a
settlement
however it could change or since
becoming a regular
um my kill Tony sets have been changing
you know
it's just an interesting thing
it's just like a living breathing
organism where I'm trying to do really
good on kill Tony and I don't want to do
bad
what's the structure of a good joke
something that you care about something
that means a lot to you something that
you uh can be emotionally invested in
um
yeah I mean I love a good joke
I love when the joke says something
so still for me
now that God
I think I'm gonna build here first
just because
um
I don't want anyone to steal this spot
this spot is more secure it's going to
take a long time for him to go all the
way around for this guy to come all the
way here
uh should I
foreign
[Music]
so I don't know kill Tony is such an
exciting thing every week it comes
around it's like a party it's like where
all the comedians meet up and hang out
and get to know each other
so
um
I mean
oh I'm always excited for it and because
it's such a big thing like I don't want
to bomb on it so I want to do a good job
and then there's the pressure of that
and all the all this stress and headache
that comes with stuff like that
um
yeah so
it's just interesting
it's a fun time it's stressful in a good
way because it makes me be like I can't
be lazy I gotta be on top of my game and
do things correctly
so that's good I forgot I had the three
to one part
I haven't made any mistakes today or to
this game the thing about Katan is like
I'm always searching for that perfect
game where I make All the Right Moves
you know the dies do whatever they do
but as long as I Do the Right Moves
uh it's
it's uh it's all you can do is do the
right thing when it's your turn God damn
it
sheepy
[Music]
I'm not a millionaire defiq Delph
deferential deferential calculus you
mean differential calculus
differential calculus with the E is like
where you're super respectful calculus
where you're super respectful diff EQ
differential
calculus is something that I took in
high school
it just got so theoretical
that I don't really know
I don't really know how much I know
about it now
I've never met Bobby Lee no I literally
went to the same Community College as
Bobby Lee
like the song called me maybe I used to
love the song Call Me Maybe
it's a great song about calling you
maybe
um
my life is pretty amazing you know it
hasn't always been the case so I feel
like I get to say it now
um I've been having a good life I've
been just trying to keep it up
trying not to get in trouble or lose the
position just trying to maintain
you know it's been a long time nine
years in the game so it's like I sort of
deserve it but what does deserve really
mean
I mean I think like
I'm having a good time and that's the
most important thing
but uh and
um
yeah I mean
I I don't want to get arrogant or
lose the spot that I have in any way
or you know [ __ ] it up or anything
um so that's my primary goal and then
after I don't [ __ ] it up I want to do
good and uh you know have like
uh uh a career that is awesome and like
jokes that are awesome and like amazing
and like
having really great jokes is a priority
of mine
so yeah it's just all sorts of things I
need to do
I need sheep
and then we got sheep
who is Emma blue
[ __ ]
her hair shape
I think I should trade this in
uh there should be a kill Tony regular
tour yeah we tried to do that
unfortunately William has to go uh do a
gig with Duncan Trussell that day
um
so
I don't think it's gonna happen but I
might be there next week in Houston
doing a little regular tour
always puts it there black
nice it all worked out
so yeah the regular tour should be going
on soon are you capable of Anger of
course
I get really angry sometimes
it's not good
I don't want to help this guy I'll just
deal with my [ __ ]
he has one development card so he can
still [ __ ] things up
but she hasn't yet
[Music]
here we go getting this port
let me buy a development card
so I can get rid of this Knight versus
this robber Robert
this is Katan is the board game you roll
dies and the numbers are the resources
and if your number gets rolled you get
to
[ __ ] do something
I want to get this spot right here
that's what I'm aiming for
unfortunately this guy is very tied to
me
anything that I get he gets too
um
oh yeah I mean
I think that uh Donald Trump being rated
is predictable and
probably for the best
you can't let a guy like that do
whatever he wants he needs to be kept in
check
um
and I think it's a good thing that he's
being kept in check
they don't want him going crazy out
there
foreign
close game everyone's the same number of
points
hopefully he doesn't steal from me
God damn it
my one rock what the [ __ ]
what are the chances 20 percent
[ __ ] he took my rock
this [ __ ]
I'm having any Rock
I can go here but it's a bit of a track
so
um
what the deal with Trump is is that he
is like a megalomaniac crazy guy and
then everyone wants to act like that's
normal
it is atypical to be sure
um what should we talk about Google News
Trump FBI raised Trump's Diggs GOP
response kaching
we're like how dare you
how dare you investigate
you should never investigate
um
I feel like
um
foreign I feel like it's deserved
but I've already said that a million
times now
um yeah I mean what do you guys think
about uh Trump what a crazy guy huh
what a crazy knucklehead
please come back to Chicago
I'll love to go back to Chicago
Chicago is a great City it's my kind of
town Chicago is my kind of town it's a
great town I love that they created a
city I feel like their public transit
could not just be Suburban focused but
also focused on other neighborhoods
like connecting suburbs with each other
instead of just everything going
downtown
um
Trump pleaded the fifth which is
obviously means he's not guilty
uh
yeah he doesn't want to incriminate
himself
I wish I didn't trade with him
but a man's got to do what a man's got
to do
he doesn't even have any ports
I need sheep
um
yeah I mean
I hate when people would be like well
you don't do that to a Democrat you
don't invade a Democrats [ __ ] thing
yeah because no Democrat has done the
things that Trump has done Trump is way
worse
it's
like
who are we getting here
I need a sheepy
I don't think he has much
oh I just got wheat
you got two wheat
I could have waited
I didn't have to give that guy a brick
what I need is two wood
then I can build where I want to build
God damn it
that's a lot of cards
and he has a brick Port oh [ __ ]
God damn it
I got [ __ ]
I didn't realize they had the brick Port
oh I should have known
anyways
there should be rules
borrowing 62 year old presidents yeah
Biden is like 79.
um but yeah uh
too bad that
people are so old
I'm in last place
black
what choice do I have with the trade
with the Devil
foreign
geriatric Olympics 2024 well that's
there's a reason why everyone in
government is so old it's because those
are the only people that can run a
government or who are
uh allowed to run our government
um
the government is made for old people by
old people it's like FUBU but for
geriatric people
it's the only people who can uh control
it because the whole system is meant to
preserve wealth as it is right now
and it's a old thing it's like look at
the people that run it and that's the
type of uh
that's the type of vibe it is
like it's an old decrepit system that is
corrupt and slow and it's not a good
system it's only meant for
uh simplistic things and dumb things
uh
yeah it's an old system that we're
trying to keep in place well past its
prime it's like a [ __ ] Biden is
like what the place is it's like an old
thing
and uh
we're we're just keeping it alive
it's an old stupid thing
I don't need to be trading with people
right now
um
yeah it's an old system meant for old
people
and we should have a new system it's
like it's like a [ __ ] jalopy
it's an old [ __ ] car that we have
when we could be driving around in a
Rolls-Royce we have this old Biden car
and we don't have a new Fresh car we
need a new system of government we don't
just have to be preserving this old
government that we have from the 1700s
and just worship it
the best way to recover the economy is
to worship the old system and hope that
Benjamin Franklin blesses us
we shouldn't try to improve upon
the system that we have instead we
should just
worship harder and praise our
forefathers more
um
it's uh
it's the right thing to do
we shouldn't try to think for ourselves
um but yeah so it's like maybe for a new
world we need a new way of doing things
huh
does that sound like a good idea
maybe we should try improving things
somewhat slightly
um but yeah
it's just an interesting
old system that we have because we like
old things the older the better
keep it all and keep it cold
that's the good thing about our
political system well I I think ideally
we would improve upon it
but we don't want to improve upon it we
want to keep it the same because
the people who are in charge want to
keep the wealth distribution as it is
I said that so many times
and um
and they use the cover of oh we gotta
worship the old things as a way to be
like
not changing anything so instead of not
improving
upon it why don't we improve upon it
um
I think like uh
I think yeah that's what I think I think
we should improve upon it
I'm so distracted
uh they try to raise the whatever
cowabunga
what should I build with all this might
I could get the longest road get eight
points
I'd rather just do this
and then build a settlement
and then eventually get along this road
but yeah I mean we have an old system
and the reason why it's old is so that
it can remain the same but improvements
are awesome and we should definitely
improve things
Improvement is necessary
all I need is one more point and then I
win and then actually I need three more
points but I can get one more point with
the road so all I need is a road and
then one more point
oh he says GG
I should have gotten the longest road
because that just set him up to get it
I don't realize he had so many [ __ ]
Road building materials
damn I should have just gotten an of the
longest road
so that he would have had to build one
more road to get it
and then I would have had nine or eight
points
oh well that was a close game Hans as an
expert do you think we are heading
towards world war three
um
I think that we are headed towards the
end of the way that we're doing things
now
uh however that is gonna be I don't know
but this is definitely not sustainable
uh second Cold War
well yeah I think um
that we are headed towards the end of
what what is happening now I think we
need a new way of thinking about things
and a new priority just a profit motive
isn't the best you know you need more
than just the profit motive you need
um lots of different uh
ways of motivating yourself and uh not
being selfish and uh looking out for the
good of people I think is important
um and I think we need a new priority we
can't just be like my goal in life is to
make money and to succeed and win
because that produces horrible societies
and horrible outcomes and genocides and
famines and Mass
um murders and stuff
so I think that uh we need to find a new
way of being a human there's humans are
so adaptable and we're stuck in this one
little narrow virus-like way of thinking
like where we're like more and more and
more I need money give me stuff I need
to take and consume as much as I can and
the more you get the less I have so I
want you to do less and I want me to
have more like this is like such a
primitive and simple and limiting way of
being a human and yet that is the
primary way that people are humans
nowadays so I think we need to have less
of that and more of a higher uh the more
evolved purpose as opposed to just
accumulating material wealth
um Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan which was
ill-advised
um I wish that she hadn't done that I
think that there's no reason to go over
there and stir things up I think it's
bad for Taiwan I don't think it's good
for everyone
um
yeah
so
what else what else
I could play another game
I could uh look up
[Music]
um
why does that fill it in
I don't want that filled in like that
like oh you meant this
let's see this is a cool background
open image in new tab
God it's so tiny
of an image a new tab why are these all
so [ __ ] tiny
there we go
down down
[Music]
but yeah
um
so you're gonna raise it thanks for
giving us Asians a voice and I'm glad
you're not a typical Boba liberal
lymphal
I don't know what a boba liberal is but
I'm guessing that's just like a guy that
uh Works in finance and then goes and
eats drinks bubble tea with his
um
girl that is only attracted for him for
his money
um
and lives a sad little pathetic life
and
um
just has a lot of material wealth and no
purpose or Soul or Vitality or a grander
purpose or a sense of vision of who he
wants to be in the world
even though he's successful
I think it's time that we all
participate in culture and if everyone
is participating
then everyone's voice is heard and we
can create a nice potpourri a little mix
of everyone's voices together
and uh then the best voices will rise to
the top and we can all create a better
world together but if everyone is just
uh uh everyone is just like [ __ ]
brain dead and working all the time and
some useless job and filling out
paperwork that no one cares about
and everyone's potential is wasted
then uh you don't have a healthy
ecosystem of thoughts and ideas and the
healthier the ecosystem the healthier
the humans and the individuals in it are
going to be and if everyone was freed
from having to worry about their
survival like animals then you would
have a much richer artist Community
you'd have a lot more inventions a lot
more cool things
help
s
GOP we hate China One Dem shows support
for Taiwan what the [ __ ] are you doing
well GOP is just reactionary they just
react to whatever is happening they're
like oh you did that we're against that
we hate that they just wanna they're the
breaks of progress they're like we're
evolving too fast we need to be more
slow and like the olden times
but
I just don't trust conservatives and the
conservative ideology how could you
trust conservatives they've been wrong
about everything I don't understand this
why we're going back to conservatism
some of us
it's like why would they be correct
about anything their mentality is
completely broken they're just only
focused on animalistic things like that
that looks wrong I hate gay things
because that looks wrong and uh they're
completely compromised by corporations
they've been wrong about slavery
conservatives have they've been wrong
about segregation gay marriage marijuana
divorce women's rights they've been
wrong about all these things like why
would we trust them the the answer is
probably progress in continuing upon the
path that the conservatives have been
stopping us from getting on
um
conservatives are not more logical
conservatives believe in the Bible and
they don't believe in stem cell research
and they believe that gay marriage is
wrong because it feels wrong
um conservatives are
pretty pretty horrible they're just not
right it's just they're just like a
weird mix of feelings and false ideas
um but yeah I mean
I think that um
I think that uh you know it's this is a
country founded on slavery and they a
lot of people don't want to admit that
so that a lot of the [ __ ] that is in our
culture they're like no that's not
slavery based that's just normal that's
just the awesome parts of America and I
think that we don't want to admit a lot
of our [ __ ] is bad and we're like no I'm
an individual I'm not affected by
history and then you let history affect
you more because you think it doesn't
affect you
um
conservatives believe in males and
females but that's not really that
important what's important is getting
poor people money and they don't believe
in helping poor people by giving them a
fair wage or paying them fairly or
helping people that are out of the
system with money just a cash cash
infusion they only believe in cash
infusions for corporations that fail and
Executives uh need a golden parachute
but not poor people who need a home and
food so that they can get their [ __ ]
together
um yeah I mean it's great that uh
transgender things are such a big deal
now but I think economically is a real
issue and liberals don't want to talk
about economics because they don't want
to give up any other money either
um so they're happy to be distracted by
transgender issues and fight on that
front instead of being like maybe we
should give poor people more money they
don't want to have that conversation
because they don't want to give up any
of their money
um
who are the good guys in history
probably Martin Luther King Jr probably
Gandhi
uh the libs you know a lot of them are
just benefiting off of colonialism and
our system of exploitation of third
world countries
and they don't really want to see any of
that changed I lived in a van I'm
willing to do that so if I'm willing to
live in a van then I don't mind giving
more money to poor people I think that
it would be great for everyone I would
rather have gas stations where I'm not
afraid of getting knifed and having
poverty where people are incentivized to
steal from me like that's why I am so
afraid of the poor is because if I was
poor and wealth was within that close of
a grasp of me I would you know do what I
had to do to survive
um
and I would
not mind hurting other people to get
what I needed just to survive so if I
can see that that's the choice that I
would make as a poor person I don't see
why they don't do that
I think that it is a testament to human
nature and the good in people that most
homeless people don't resort to crime
and violence but if that's the only
option that I'm left with then a society
that has abandoned me like that does not
deserve my discipline so I don't know
why more homeless people wouldn't attack
me so ideally uh I would like to live in
a world where people like that don't
exist so they don't I don't have to be
physically worried about my safety
because I would do that in their
situation I would probably resort to
violence if I had to if I was poor
um
and a lot of poor people do and a lot of
people a lot more poor people don't
which is amazing and uh yeah I mean if I
can't understand if I can understand why
they would want to hurt me and take from
me then
I am going to be afraid and I'm gonna
live in fear and stress and I'd rather
not have that I'd rather have poor
people be given taxpayers money
hopefully from a corporation or a rich
person and get them to a position where
they don't need to Rob and steal from
other people to survive and unless that
happens I'm I'm going to be wary of that
situation so I would rather uh you know
get rid of that
[Music]
um
I'd rather get rid of that
uh stress by giving poor people money
and helping them out
there's a lot of a lot of people in
society who don't strive to do better
and just continue getting free money
well I don't think that's a big problem
right now
I think a bigger problem is Corporate
handouts and like bailing out big Banks
or whatever I don't think that a big
problem right now is that there's a lot
of people sitting in trailer parks
collecting checks I think that the
problem is that there isn't enough
checks going to trailer parks
and I think if there was there would be
less domestic abuse there'd be less
child abuse there'd be fewer sex crimes
everything will get better but as long
as money is trapped up top uh everything
will get worse and that's what this is
all about is like creating a wealth
inequality and preserving it by the rich
what are the rich love the most what is
this whole country and this whole
economy run on money money is the key if
we can Liberate the money from the
places where it's trapped and stagnating
then the society will become better and
I'm not saying that because I want more
money I'm saying that because I don't
want to live with poor people I want to
live with people that are striving or
thriving
I want to live with people that are
amazing doing cool things with their
life not just trying to get a [ __ ]
cheeseburger from Arby's
and think Arby's has cheeseburgers
do you believe Yang should have been
president I mean nobody voted for him
um I am not that familiar with all of
his works but I did go to a rally that
he did and I was uh moved and I was
inspired
that he was entering politics because
you know it takes courage to be like my
voice deserves to be heard
and I think everyone should do that
everyone should
say what they have to say and see how
big of a platform they get and he got a
big platform he made a big splash and I
respect that right here bro I'll send
you my cash app while I'd have to verify
that you're poor and that you actually
deserve it
but um
yeah I would love to get rid of poor
people
lost a lot of people in society here now
let's bring something that's
understandable doesn't mean
it is justifiable yeah I mean I would
probably not hurt people just because
that hurts people
but if you put people in a position
where that that's one of their only
options then
then that's a horrible situation because
then you're just relying on the goodness
of people that's the thing is like
people are like people are naturally
evil so we have to starve them and make
sure that they're not too rich because
then they'll use those riches for evil
but then you starve people and then you
treat them like [ __ ] and they still
don't attack you and they don't they
don't hurt you so these people that are
like humans are naturally evil are
relying on the natural goodness of
humans to keep being evil to them it's
like if humans were naturally evil you
wouldn't exist because of all the evil
[ __ ] that you did to them and how
they're just turning the other cheek
like if it was just like people were
just animals then it would be like they
would attack you rightfully because
you're treating them horribly but
fortunately people are good and into
horrible situations they choose the
right option and they choose peace and
love while you with all your money and
luxury choose to be mean and spiteful to
poor people
um as a exercise as like a as an
abnormal thing because it takes an extra
layer of thinking to be like Oh I'm
gonna be mean now even though I
shouldn't obviously be a good person so
I think it's a very unnatural act to be
like [ __ ] poor people they just need
tough love
foreign
it's unhuman inhuman to do that to watch
someone suffer and then not help them
tax low wage hourly workers to fund gbi
for people who don't work at all is what
we'll get why don't we tax the people
that are sitting on their asses on
Yachts all day who are just accruing the
value of Millennials and genziers Uber
eating for them
um there's plenty of rich people and
just because this is how the money fell
uh after slavery and segregation does
not mean that this is the right way for
the wealth to be distributed in a
society that makes it better or fair for
everyone involved how many janitors and
you know seamstresses and uh Factory
workers
who are poor and immigrants
do we know that work way harder than uh
than [ __ ] CEOs and they don't get
paid as much it's not a fair system it's
you don't get paid based on the value
that you create or the work that you put
in you get paid based on how much you
can take and the more that you took
earlier on the more of an advantage you
have and then you can compound that
interest
you can compound that advantage and uh
become more and more successful at the
expense of everyone else
because they're just starting the game
late because they were genocided or they
were sick or they were a woman or
they came to the country late
I mean it's it's not a good system the
way we have it now it's not a
meritocracy and we're just getting away
with it because we have so much wealth
and because we colonized and destroyed
so many other countries that they don't
have the opportunity to succeed that we
do we stored all their the loot from the
world here
and this is the only place that you can
um you know build on top of that loot
because the people in Guatemala don't
have all that banana money that we stole
from them money is a root of unlock the
money
there will always be violent homeless
when we don't treat mental illness like
it's a real like Ben said something we
ignore on some level isn't money an
indicator of the choices you make in
life yeah I think money right now is an
indicator of our history and where it
falls is probably an indicator of the
people who have had an advantage in our
society for a longer period of time
rather than skill or Merit I think it's
just a I think America
improved upon feudalism
with uh capitalism
instead of worshiping a king now we
worship capitalists and people who own
capital and factories
um
and uh it was an improvement upon
feudalism for sure but we need to keep
on improving upon it especially with the
amount of resources and of technology
that we have capitalists can now have an
even deeper Advantage
than just
um in the past where you still had to
have all these looms and you know have
all these people fixing the Looms and
right now you just need one robot to
replace 500 workers and so if you give
all the money to people who own that
robot then everyone else is going to
starve to death so you're going to have
to do something eventually
uh it's a level
um
yeah so if you owned the factory in 1920
and you just keep making money off that
factory and keep buying and improving
your factory because no one else has the
money to improve theirs and then you
accrue your benefits then that's just a
testament to the fact that you had an
advantage for a long time it's not
necessarily a test competence although
it does take a level of confidence to do
that but that doesn't mean that someone
else couldn't do it better it's just
that they don't have the opportunity to
try
they did burn it really dirty yeah they
[ __ ] them up the Democratic party they
didn't want Bernie in the into to win so
they [ __ ] it up even though he was the
Natural Choice of our society we
instinctively reached out to Bernie and
voted for him in whatever way the
[ __ ] primaries work and they were
like nope even our limited version of
democracy that we have in the
Democratic primaries was thwarted they
were like no you can't do that even
though we totally rigged the [ __ ]
primaries anyways it's not rigged enough
for us we've got to rig at one extra
step and Bernie got shafted he's 80
[ __ ] 20. 80
87 89 years old now and we already
missed the boat on Bernie we don't
deserve Bernie we are uh too corrupt of
a society to have Bernie
and instead Hillary became the nominee
and then she lost so you know we felt it
in our bones we're like this isn't what
we wanted this isn't the best Democratic
we like even changed our thinking to be
Democrat versus Republican and we're
like well if that's the case then Bernie
would be the right answer to
you know answer the the thing with Trump
because we're like the things that we
did in the past is not working we don't
need more of Hillary Clinton we need
something different and we instinctively
reached out to Bernie uh the Republican
idiots reached out to Trump that's their
solution for our problems is this
ridiculous man they're they're gone
they're they're too too [ __ ] up
they're way off the beaten path they're
lost
but we had Bernie and then we didn't put
him up to run against him so we're like
this doesn't make any sense
I guess if they sell the these are the
options might as well switch things up a
bit shake things up
I mean capitalism is where people who
own capital
um are given more power
and I just don't think that they need
more power I think that they have enough
power why do we have to change our whole
system for them
we should Empower more low wage and
worker
Working Class People
and I think that uh if everyone is
better then we can be the sum of our
parts instead of worshiping a lord or a
baron or a king we can all be awesome
and that'll make the world awesome look
how awesome people are now even with
capitalism where it's not a guarantee
that you'll be rewarded
okay I think I came back
um
free enterprise is clear the best method
to create the largest surpluses of goods
along with a society that has a
sufficient degree of freedom
free enterprise means that business
people doing whatever the [ __ ] they want
if business people did whatever the [ __ ]
they wanted we wouldn't have weekends
children would be working in fact
um you would be able to sell your
children
for money
we have what we have now because we have
fire departments and the SEC and the EPA
and the FAA and highways so we never
really had
um
free enterprise it's always been checked
by Common Sense and decency the biggest
game is being tested on money that we
make than taxing us when we spend it and
texting us on property that we own that
we already paid taxes on with our
already taxed money
but we use roads all the time we use
water all the time and those things cost
money and that should be coming out of
something
I think uh if you're not happy with the
level that we're being taxed then we can
change it democratically but
we should pay for things
I don't mind paying for things you know
we live in an awesome Society
so
um Jordan Peterson
apparently it makes good points about
how liberalism and conservatism is
necessary so we don't destroy ourselves
I think that's just the way that it is
now I don't think that's necessarily the
best way I think it's just
I think it's just how it happens to be
[Music]
um
this thing is red
now it's yellow green hooray I think I'm
back
uh I think conservatism and liberalism
is just how it is now I don't think it's
necessarily how it's supposed to be I
think uh more healthy discussion would
be better I think uh having people not
on the left or the right would be better
I think just
being like how normal humans are that
should be how our economy and our
politics is
just raise minimum wage keep the
capitalism
you're never going to be able to raise
the minimum wage if you have capitalism
because capitalism is where rich people
decide everything if rich people decide
everything why would they decide to just
[ __ ] themselves they're going to vote in
their best interest and they're going to
pay politicians to get what they want
um
if you just raise minimum wage that's
not good enough we need true power the
people should have the power the people
should be able to decide what the people
do not a small group of people telling
us what we should do and it might not be
perfect because people are dumb but at
least we don't have anyone to blame but
ourselves we're looking at people that
don't have any power and be like look
what would happen if we give them power
but if you gave them power then we'd
start studying then we'd start learning
and we'd make better decisions but right
now we don't have that power so we're
not developing we're stagnant we're
intellectually bereft because we are not
asked to use our intellect all that the
purpose of our society is and the only
purpose that people are given is to not
[ __ ] [ __ ] up too much and to keep it the
way it is their incentive isn't to
create awesome people it's to create
people that aren't going to change
things so that's why people are so dumb
and broken if you give people like that
power then it's not good but if you
create people that are a part of the
system that they live in then they're
going to be better people
we need to power to be in the hands of
the people we need to decide what
happens to us no one should decide for
us what happens to us
if we want something we should get it
we shouldn't just have a couple of
billionaires deciding what the [ __ ] that
we get to do if it's us that is going to
be impacted then we should decide what
we want to do
the people in a vote
not just a billionaire deciding what we
need now is tunnels under LA and then
never doing it
so what is your what is your prognosis
should we lean more towards Trump or
Bernie Sanders that is the options that
we have and if you're more towards Trump
then it's
um not gonna work out because he's crazy
and he's just emotionally a good time
what is the emotion ever the right
answer when it's like the choose the
answer that feels the best it feels the
best to [ __ ] trash your room and you
know break your windows and [ __ ] yell
really loud but that doesn't mean that's
the best way to keep your house going
as imperfect as capitalism is it does
allow for class Mobility something other
systems didn't support
well uh if you look at America we are
27th in Social mobility and we have the
lowest social safety net
um a system that rewards Capital owners
and makes life easier for them and gives
them more money isn't going to be a
great system for social Mobility I'm
sure capitalism is better at Social
Mobility than feudalism because you
can't just be a king you have to be born
a king
but it is not better than some of the
other systems of government that we
could try out which other countries have
tried to try out but then they get
visited by the CIA and their experiment
comes to a swift end
and just ask Allende
or the mumba
we need to progress past capitalism we
need a system that doesn't just support
rich people and makes life easier for
rich people
there's much more to Trump than most
people think and you're going to be
pleasantly surprised when the truth
comes to light
ratusite us
um I mean it'd be nice if there was more
to Trump than what most people thought
but I don't think there is I think it's
he's just an idiot and he's just running
around yelling and everyone's like oh
look it's so cool and fun yeah it feels
good but I don't think there's anything
there if there was it would have come
out by now
all he wants to do is just do things
that feel good
and there's no way to run a country you
need to think about things and figure
things out
can I buy your van to live in purchase I
would love it if someone purchased my
van
um I'm probably gonna ask a lot for it
maybe I shouldn't if you want to buy it
let me know
well we don't have that power because of
all the distractions and surroundings do
you own a house now whoa whoa shots
fired at Elon oh yeah you and William
need to do a podcast on politics
I mean I think that would be great
because I love talking about boring
stuff and then William is like fun and
entertaining so it'd be a nice yin and
yang
like there could be a serious Jesus
issue that affects the solid drastically
but
insert Tick Tock dances Elon Republic of
Austin Trump Bernie Shifty though how's
Bernie Shifty he's like the most
trustworthy guy ever he's boring he's
old he doesn't do [ __ ]
full send only consider burning on the
left to interview hola
we should all vote for Bernie so he can
die happy hopefully not in office yeah
what if it's like a uh Ruth Bader
Ginsburg scenario
big issue is nobody knows what they're
talking about how many people actually
know the details to know if Hillary
Trump actually broke the law but talk
like they know
um
I mean I think that's on purpose I think
we're kept ignorant on purpose so that
no one can change anything
how's the Spirits by Isabel Allende
you know Trump 2024. the swamp is deep
us I need a van Bernie's been around all
this time it only runs in 2016 all this
[ __ ] dude it could have used you earlier
well it's like the thing is like we
weren't ready for that we weren't ready
for Bernie
um
and um
we still aren't
we don't deserve Bernie Bernie is better
than us he is uh better than the average
person in our society but that's on
purpose
uh we've been kept dumb and docile so
that we don't change things and switch
things up what's Mark Norman's life like
off stage Mark Normand off stage is a
lot like Mark Norman on stage he's
always cracking jokes he's uh so nice he
looks at you in the eye and he talks to
you like a human being
and I heard that he's really good at uh
getting with a lot of very attractive
females
uh if you want to buy my van let me know
but thank you for tuning in I love you
guys and